[Music]
and truth be told news submitted by you
show you a former member of the boo
scandal alleges the group was really a
front for a blue prostitution ring
I knew this but I couldn't afford it if
I was Wolverine this will be my weapon
banana it looks like three pigs she
looks like oh she looks like a white
person doing Mexican face her complexion
looks very Hispanic beautiful she looks
Hispanic she's like a Jennifer Lopez
version 2.5 mm she looks like she tells
fortunes on the weekend
this is kaya John and so she's a singer
hyah
she was in the Pussycat Dolls for only
two years before they mean it bakes it
was 2003 to 2005 no she left she should
have stuck it through have been famous
instead she right before the yeah so
this is when she was she got morals she
said did she get cut because she's like
I gonna [ __ ] for money anymore
she said good I never said why they
needed 52 members you can ask cream
groups the same thing but then like it's
like I don't like who knows all their
names everyone in the comments if anyone
knows all their names listed I've got 22
percent all ran five perhaps they do
they all sing were they all singing uh I
believe so I believe that they're all
singers and dancers I know one girl was
probably only embarrassed because they
wanted someone who could do the splits
cuz every video she's like oh yeah
it was cuz you remembered what we're
talking about you're splitting and
that's what they wanted you to [ __ ]
do I could see why they have so many
girls yeah cuz once you get bored with
their singing or the song or something
then you're looking at them as are
[ __ ] hot and I'm like [ __ ] I won't be
like that we take the boy bad when you
only have that guy that hits all the
base notes you just need that they would
circle they're like this one sings one
part and no one sings the other part
like they circle in the front and then
they back out and then one goes
interesting because Tommy's at four five
six seven eight nine 10 girls 10 girls
fighting over a 3-minute track only one
that everyone knows is Nicole no one
knows the other [ __ ] girl maybe
they're the ensemble Anton's Chronos oh
she ended up squeaking out after this
whole like Harvey Weinstein delegations
and stuff she tweeted this out so I
would read it really quick because
there's a lot of my truth I wasn't in a
girl group I was in a prostitution ring
oh and we happen to sing and be famous
well everyone who owned us made the
money oh my god that's genius how bad
was it
people asked bad enough that I walked
away from my dreams
band mates and a thirteen million dollar
record deal we knew we were going to
number one where she walked away from
the prostitution ring which is her dream
no she walked away no she [ __ ] away
from being a star okay it wasn't easy
for me not to be a [ __ ] cuz it the way
it sounds it seems like we're a
prostitution ring and they forced us to
sing to be part of the team you must be
a team player
meaning sleep with whoever they say if
you don't they have nothing on you to
leverage and then like she continued
with more tweets
and then so she says it's best to not
get defensive and attack when you're
guilty sorry your house of cards is done
everyone will soon know soon know the
truth I love how predators enjoy playing
the victim pathetic
so prostitution is analogous it's not a
direct definition of what it wasn't
exactly so she's saying that it was like
a prostitution ring with the
prostitution who got it got my attention
for sure I was like I see it that's
really wrong but I think it's genius
because check this out I've been saying
I haven't told you guys personally but
I've been saying this for a very long
time that it's it's probably true that
really really really rich people propose
celebrities a lot of money like sleep
with me for two million dollars or just
keep me company
or maybe just give me a [ __ ] for like
five million dollars I just felt it I
had the senses just telling me well for
her she's saying that it wasn't in
exchange for money it was like to
further their career to climb up the
level Oh like I want to roll in a movie
well you got a [ __ ] Harvey Weinstein
yeah so it's like favor for a favor
pretty much she's saying that it was I
can understand her like so the founder
of this group Pussycat Dolls her name is
Robin Acton this is what she looks like
I mean a lot of girl groups so she's the
master Pussycat yeah and so she was
saying that Robin is the the help like
hell's den mother or something don't you
like the Mamas oh yeah of the brothel
sweetie I want the den mother from Hell
to confess why another one of her girl
group girl group girls committed suicide
tell us how you mentally broke up and
she's referring to the most battle who
was a part of the girl group called girl
GRL and this is alone here she ended up
committing suicide suicide back in 2014
when she was 25 years old she hung
herself and then they're saying that she
kya is alleging like Robin broke us down
so much that even like one of her girls
committed suicide I saw mean dad those
girls are [ __ ] hot we're all these
girls
here god damn she's cute they got an
audition for that [ __ ] how much would
you pay to be in a room not you now but
18 year old you would you pay to be in a
room with all those women doing all five
of them
just in a room I'm not saying that they
do anything for you but just be in a
room with that 18 million dollars a
million dollars just to be in a room and
had them talk to you yeah just to talk
to them no no I would want them to all
be naked we could slither around like
[ __ ] snails without shells that's
what he wants to do as horny as I am at
18 I was real I was even more cheaper
than I am now I'm just I was so cheap I
was the kind of guy that will go to the
strip club and be sceptical and think
that lap dance is probably not gonna be
that good it's not worth twenty dollars
I wasted money on love dance yeah um I
am so cheap when it comes to girls so
then for you you would pay what nothing
I would be the shyster that tries to
like scam them and - hanging out with me
for free because that looks like every
photographic memory because then those
guys that are geniuses like that they
can just go to strip clubs no tweets she
says I finally feel the weight I've held
in my heart lifted and mending it's been
hard to hold lies in for people who
broke me no more Robin and the record
label made all the money we as Pussycat
Dolls were paid $500 a week while we
were being abused and used fact to
anyone thinking I've made this up why
would I want to have a target on my back
slash claim to have been using abuse not
exactly a good look
why didn't I don't we report it because
we all are abused I personally have been
warned if I tell I will you know end up
dead or normally we're in 24 in 2004 I
told Hollywood executives in 2005-2006
I told press in 2011 I spoke up again
hope you can hear me now media and 2017
way to go thumbs up and so this is like
her whole allegations Robin
she ended up saying like this is
absolutely ridiculous like all her
claims are false she's just looking for
her 15 minutes of fame the [ __ ] the
Pussycat Dolls The Pussycat Doll they
gave a statement as well saying that
they cannot stand behind false
allegations toward other group members
partaking in activities that simply did
not take place the Pussycat Dolls has up
has always and will always stand for
female empowerment and sisterhood we
stand in solidarity with all women who
had bravely spoken public publicly of
their horrific experiences of abuse
harassment and exploitation you could
stand in public for it doesn't mean it
didn't happen
mm-hmm that's so sad about trying to
take sides or anything but the map just
didn't make sense to me a little bit
because she says she left before they
signed a 13 million dollar contract but
then she said they would pay $500 a week
I'm like if you didn't break it big yet
of course I've learned always a week
makes sense saying mmm that's it I think
there's too many people that are so
desperate at Hollywood like there's
people that would probably step on a
puppy and kill their own grandma just to
become famous do it for ya but for less
yeah there's people that done that for
less do you know some stories do you
want to share something because I know
you know a lot of stuff I do and all I'm
saying is all I'm saying okay I'll let
you complete that let me just do this
[ __ ] real quick if there was a union of
artists that said I sucking dick for
money
[ __ ] that [ __ ] and it got together it
would be a better place yeah
but what about the people that do want
to suck dick they should start their own
your end
yeah separating could end all the don't
you want but for example like you know
like the the what is it called the dark
web right or like the [ __ ] Silk Road
black market [ __ ] if you don't want to
partake in that world don't be in that
world don't sign off to the dress where
I can buy [ __ ] on PayPal
regular [ __ ] and if you do want to be in
that other world be in that other world
yeah and they don't have to end up
interconnect I think what's happening
here though is that a lot of people like
the general public they don't know that
this happens like this is the norm in
the industry and so now she's like
saying like her own experiences so then
everyone knows like hey've this is
actually the way it is in the music's
what she needs to do it is hire one of
those planes that writes letters in the
air yes and then with [ __ ] cloud
letters it says did you know that you
have to suck a dick to the whole world
so now we all know and now we separate
the dog this is her way of doing it on
Twitter I read a lot of time on the
beach belly we've done you're never on
Twitter the rest of the web and Emily I
want to see those two unions happen have
you ever been to the beach and seen
those those airplanes fly that's the
only thing you see in the sky if I was
there I'm like what it is either
you have to suck a dick to become famous
what an abomination and I think we were
all marked yeah we would march from the
freakin oh yeah Gina go ahead sounds in
another country right doing a great
Dubai okay and not like because we've
always say that you're always [ __ ] in
other countries know which boats the
problem if she did know I [ __ ] other
countries don't know shame in that
so I was in I was in Germany and I was
doing a meet and greet out there and
then we were all like being the the
prudently promotions and my sustainer
where they're showing me around Germany
they were like an hour last night
they're like see now let's go to those
bar like you know how they like some
hotel is that like really nice bars yeah
like this is the hotel yes which would
stay up but then the girl that I was
with decide her bring her boyfriend so
we can stay in hotel because it's
constant whatever fight and then so he
went to the bar and then they're like
yeah last time we were here we brought
some other models from the US and they
they one of them because there's two of
them
they may or may not look like each other
because they may or may not be related
oh I slept with one of the managers or
the owners or whatever of the hotel room
just see it's a presidential suite
I mean she's I mean she's been very
ambitious girl give me my
the room the presidential suite is
pretty expensive it's like three
thousand dollars okay obviously value
your [ __ ] more than she does for sure
under utilizing your [ __ ] I wonder
what I wonder what happens when a guy
goes through the sex change and becomes
a beautiful woman yes he still had the
same thoughts that guy would have if he
had a [ __ ] oh yeah if I was a girl I
would use my [ __ ] to give me into
fireplaces cuz it would make it would be
you would be like literally having a
magic Genie lamp you know for a guy yeah
if I'm thinking how a typical guy thinks
you know what I mean because you know
guys are still guys doesn't matter if
you're gay or whatever what now guys are
still guys yeah so if I was if I happen
to got like four million dollars with
the surgery I turned to this hot-ass
[ __ ] never never happen not with four
million four million but you know like I
think I probably would have used my
[ __ ] for my own benefit I think like
honestly what if it was like this I
because I can't use my dick for my own
benefit you mean you can you can't use
your dick and be like I can but then the
girl would have to have really low
self-esteem to go through a lady swab
ass dudes that actually were close yes
sure I mean if women are to use their
sexual things to make money all the
powers that you do they go you know it's
not fair cuz I will never know what that
feels like so I could only imagine to
have the superpower of the I know but
you know what at the end of the day
though this is kind of cool that
everyone's coming out and talking about
the [ __ ] because we all need to hear
this [ __ ] so people in Hollywood
could change the [ __ ] it's funny the
way that you put it like it's like a
genie thing because it's like you know
like you tell a genie or a wish and he
always goes around and [ __ ] random
ass loops and [ __ ] you're like I wish I
had all the power and money and everyone
gives me [ __ ] like how women get it all
right
ugly ass moment there you gotta have a
[ __ ] no go hey guys thanks for watching
that last episode did you love it I know
you did but guess what you can also
follow us on our personal social media
accounts with the links in the
description box below so go follow all
of us now to watch more videos
there
[Music]